RETO MEIER: Hi, my name
is Reto Meier.
I'm the tech lead for
Google's Android
Developer Relations team.
Every time your app initiates
a data connection, no matter
how much data it transfers,
you cause a typical 3G
wireless radio to continue
drawing power for upwards of
20 seconds.
This efficient data transfer's
DevByte will look at how you
can use tools like SyncAdapters
to batch and
bundle your data transfers,
effectively phase shifting
them to produce a highly
efficient, defragmented
network traffic profile
like this one.
The underlying philosophy is
to reduce the number of
transfer sessions by designing
for a small
number of large downloads.
We can do that by batching up
all of our delay tolerant
transfers and bundling them
together with time sensitive
ones, potentially
even preempting
planned future transfers.
For example, if your app uses
analytics, rather than
uploading data as it's collected
you can bundle the
results together queuing them
for later upload when your app
performs a time-sensitive
download.
Similarly, any time sensitive
transfers should also preempt
updates or prefetching
scheduled to
occur in the near future.
In each case you're attempting
to mitigate the cost of the
transfer either with a delay
tolerant upload, or a planned
future download by having them
piggyback on the time
sensitive ones.
So now let's look at some
techniques that you can use to
implement these best
practices.
You can start by creating a
batch queue to offset those
delay tolerant uploads.
This code snippet shows a simple
queue to which you can
add either upload or download
transfers that should occur in
the future.
Then, whenever you execute a
time sensitive on-demand
download, or the next periodic
update or prefetch is
initiated, you can also execute
the transfer stored in
your queue.
This simple approach can be
effective but, implemented
naively, it introduces the risk
of transfers being lost
if your app is closed before
the queue is cleared.
That's fine if your queue
transfers are only relevant to
the current session, but for
things like analytics or user
created data, you want
to make sure that
you never lose anything.
The best solution is using
a content provider.
This skeleton implementation
shows the basic query, insert,
delete, and update
methods that you
would need to implement.
A content provider can be backed
by any data store, but
most commonly an SQLite
database.
Now, rather than implementing a
batch queue, you can insert
data into your content
provider.
And then when your next transfer
begins, query it for
pending transfers and remove
successfully transmitted data
from that queue.
In this example I'm querying
four queue check-ins, sending
them to a server and removing
the successfully completed
ones from the queue.
I still need a technique to
bundle these delay tolerant
transfers for the time sensitive
ones, or possibly
also reschedule those transfers
periodically to
ensure that they do
eventually happen.
Most simply, I can revisit the
earlier approach of creating a
series of methods to execute
each transfer and then ensure
that each calls the other.
A much neater alternative
is to use a SyncAdapter.
That's going to execute each of
our transfers within its on
perform sync method.
It's important to note that
each of the methods called
should contain its own logic for
determining whether or not
it should actually perform an
update, potentially skipping
transfer sessions if the radio
hasn't already been activated
by a higher priority method.
Using a SyncAdapter to manage
your transfers has a number of
advantages, including making it
easy to centralize all of
your app's data transfers in one
place so they all run at
the same time.
Your data transfers can also
be scheduled with transfers
from other apps, all working
towards the goal of reducing
the number of times the system
has to switch on the radio.
SyncAdapter also implements data
transfer best practices
for you, including checking
for network connectivity,
retrying downloads when
connectivity returns, and
automated batching and time
shifting on requests that
occur within the same
time window.
Creating a SyncAdapter
is actually pretty
straightforward.
Start by extending the abstract
threaded SyncAdapter
class and implementing your own
data transfer code within
the onPerformSync handler
as you can see here.
When executing the SyncAdapter,
we'll spawn a
thread to invoke sync
operations, so you don't need
to worry about moving your code
into a background thread.
Similarly, multiple executions
will be rejected so you can
write your transfer code knowing
that it won't be run
concurrently with itself.
In order to run, the SyncAdapter
must be bound to a
service, so you also need
to create a service that
instantiates your SyncAdapter
and binds to it.
SyncAdapters were originally
designed to support
synchronization of a
content provider
associated with an account.
For example, Gmail.
As a result, you also need to
associate each SyncAdapter
with an account type and a
content provider authority.
If you don't use accounts for
your application, you can
create your own mock account
by extending the abstract
account authenticator.
In this boilerplate, you'll
notice that I'm overriding the
add account method.
Here you would typically ask
the user to enter their
authentication details
for your service.
But instead, you can just create
a new stub account and
explicitly add it to the
Account Manager.
Take particular note of the
account type you specify.
Like the SyncAdapter, the
account authenticator also
needs a service from which to
run, so create a new service
that binds to your
implementation.
Then create a metadata
file for your account
authenticator.
Note in particular the account
type, whic must match the one
which you provided earlier
in your implementation.
The SyncAdapter also requires
a content provider.
As we described earlier, a
content provider is an
effective and efficient way to
store the data that you're
planning to transfer.
But if you prefer not to use one
you can create a stubbed
out implementation like this.
Next, create the metadata file
for the SyncAdapter that will
be used to associate a
content provider and
account type with it.
Note that here I am marking the
SyncAdapter as not user
visible, so users won't be able
to disable syncing from
their global settings.
Finally, add the new services
and content providers to the
application manifest,
associating the SyncAdapter
metadata with the SyncAdapter
service, the account
authenticator, metadata
with the account
authenticator service.
With your SyncAdapter complete
you can now start thinking
about how to trigger your
synchronizations.
And you can configure your
SyncAdapter to run when server
data changes, when the data on
the device changes, when the
framework sends a network Tcl,
or at predetermined intervals,
or even on demand.
To be as efficient as possible,
it's best practice
to rely primarily on server
initiated synchronizations,
and where possible, avoid
starting syncs as the direct
result of a user action.
Basically, try and eliminate
the Refresh button.
The hardest part of the process
is determining which
transfers are delay tolerant and
which will require a sync
to be initiated.
Now, this flow chart gives an
indication of the most common
initiators for possible syncs.
And I'll go through each flow
now demonstrating how to
trigger a SyncAdapter
in each case.
The best approach is to rely on
server pings notifying your
app that there is new
data to download.
Using Google Cloud Messaging--
which I'll explore in more
detail in another DevByte--
you can notify each installed
instance of your app that it
needs to sync with the server.
Simply listen for an incoming
GCM message notifying you of
new data becoming available,
and call requests syncs
specifying the appropriate
account and authority.
This eliminates the need for any
client side polling while
maintaining constantly
up-to-date client data.
Conversely, you may want to
synchronize changes on the
client side to the Cloud.
Now, this could be anything
from analytics data to new
emails, so you want to be
careful when deciding which
changes are sufficient to
initiate an actual transfer.
If you're using content
providers, you can configure
your SyncAdapter to trigger
whenever the content provider
changes by setting the
supports uploading
attribute to true.
Which happens to
be the default.
Now, when this is set, an
upload only sync will be
requested whenever your content
provider executes a
notify change call with the sync
to network parameter set
to true as shown here.
Now within the onPerformSync
handler you can detect these
upload only syncs by examining
the sync extras upload extra.
This can be useful if you
want to rate limit
client initiated transfers.
You can also configure your
SyncAdapter to sync whenever
the platform opens a connection
to keep the TCP/IP
connection used for things like
Google Cloud Messaging or
Live by setting it to
sync automatically.
Now this approach ensures that
your app is regularly updated
without having to schedule your
own client side polling.
Now that said, the frequency of
network Tcls can lead to a
large number of transfers, so
this should only be enabled
when your app is in
the foreground.
And even then, you may want
to artificially lower the
frequency of syncs within your
onPerformSync method.
Now, if you want to perform
regular syncs at a known
frequency, you can use the
addPeriodicSync method.
While you can set any frequency,
this approach is
more typically used to ensure
at least one sync happens
every 12 to 24 hours when the
app isn't already running.
Typically with client and server
changes initiating most
of those updates, particularly
when the app is in the
foreground.
Now finally, if you need to
initiate a time sensitive
transfer, either when the app
launches, when the user
browses something that you've
not prefetched, or just to
prefetch additional data, you
can call requestSync.
In cases where an update must
occur immediately, in order to
avoid impacting the user
experience, you can force a
manual expedited sync by
setting the manual and
expedited flags within
the settings bundle.
These settings will ignore any
back offs and sync settings
that might delay the sync
in attempt to execute it
immediately instead.
Now you can find all the details
to creating and using
SyncAdapters in this Android
training class.
So, having learned how to
perform our updates
efficiently, other DevBytes will
look at ways to adjust
our update frequency, reducing
data payload sizes, and using
Google Cloud Messaging
in more detail.